you're used to talking about why you
think girls would go for men that have a
lot of
um Power and money and all this thing
the perceived power yeah so and I
actually have a really different Theory
to you so I feel like your theory was
saying that women go for men with
perceived power and stuff but I feel
like if that was true women would go
more for like entrepreneurs and stuff
but they don't the red flags would go
for a more like drug dealers
um like criminals things like men that
can typically protect us in society and
I feel the reason we go through that is
I don't know like maybe you guys don't
understand this but the majority of
females have been essayed in some way or
they're scared to go out at night time
or they carry their keys in their hand
so the way the majority
it's not true wait that doesn't mean
that doesn't mean like to the extreme
but it is a system that a lot of women
have feel scared by men okay but if
you're gonna if you're gonna say words
and they're not true I have to like call
you out wait I'm sure there's statistics
so okay but not not the scared one you
said the majority have been sexually
assaulted yeah that doesn't mean so and
so I know what stat you're talking about
and it's the two out of three women have
been sexually like I I know what static
is and it's not true they they they they
include things like if you're drunk
having sex you've been sexually
assaulted but a lot of women don't also
report there's things that I've gone
through from my experiences women I know
a lot of girls that are majority of my
friends that have some more they say
that but but how do I know you're
telling the truth it's just your word
against his and you don't know you don't
know the other side so you can't just
believe people are we talking about
convictions yeah no no no so to me if I
if I was sexually assaulted I'd go to
the police why why wouldn't you report
it that doesn't make sense to me why
would you go around telling everyone and
not go to the police I have a girls come
on a podcast and accuse someone of
something and you don't go to the police
that doesn't make sense yeah I'm back to
your point you are realliterating what
I'm saying because what I'm talking
about is a perceived notion of status
and power and this is what they exude in
in in in in the nightlife in in society
they exude it's not real because it's
not long-lasting and there's no
longevity in it but it's a perceived
notion and number two they're in the
same age bracket when girls when women
are young they tend to want to be with a
man within the same age bracket so what
I'm saying these things are normally
obtained by a man in their 30s mid-30s
early 40s this is the average man we're
talking vast majority of men obtain this
somewhat perception and reality of
status Fame wealth maybe not the fame
part but wealth status in their mid-30s
so when you're getting it young such as
a formula
given to him young is given to him too
soon but he's still a boy he's not
matured in society yet and I know from
personal I'm sure a lot of the men can
agree men take a lot longer to mature
nobody was checking for me
yeah it takes a whole lot a whole lot
longer for a man to mature so
the point I'm making is you're going for
these kind of guys not just you
personally but girls are going for these
kind of guys but these kind of guys are
not taking assist because
they're not looking to sell that's the
point and a lot of times those those
traits it's social status like the
things you're talking about like usually
those guys are like good talkers they
have social status right because because
women like like men that other women
want yeah like um historically 40 of
women have reproduced were 80 or sorry
40 of men have reproduced where 80 of
women have
mm-hmm yeah so I wasn't going to
disagree with what you were saying I was
just going to say another that's just
another reason why girls go for a lot of
criminals and people with a lot of red
flags because they do like the idea of
having protection they want a man that's
un like Untouchable to everyone else but
touchable to them that's why I was like
if I finished off I was going to say
it's quite an immaturity thing and
that's why I feel like when women grow
up they don't want to go for the red
flags anymore it's just because they
haven't grown in themselves to realize
that's not what's really going to
protect them what they really need is a
man in a stable job in a in a stable
life with
uh ambition and goal that's why I was
trying to no you're you're right usually
usually when girls are younger they tend
to go after those things but the problem
is like it's kind of like you become
their leftovers after so like a guy
doesn't really want a girl that's been
ran through by all the toxic guys and
like the Chads they call them Chads and
tyrones I don't know why those names let
me flip it on its head why don't women
protect men
it's physically impossible no why don't
women protect men from women
like I am I can deal with men I I I'm
not scared of men I I can go I can go
head to head one versus three one versus
four one versus five I've done it before
it happened I've had to do that to
protect my woman
but
I've never been protected by a woman
against women like I am scared of women
I because I can't defend myself I'm not
allowed to
right
um in what way you mean physically or
emotionally no no no because everyone
can everyone can talk right I can I can
I can speak for myself but it happened
to me I've got S8 in this country I've
got essayed as a child by women
no one took me seriously
it it messed me up and I only realized
later in life
um
if no one protects me no one protects us
women don't like I've had I I was
walking with a girl and
we were we were kind of like debating on
the street kind of like a bit more
aggressively and I had another another
woman stranger just come at me and
literally throw insults and and the
woman that was there like she knew that
we weren't fighting or anything like
there was nothing going on but she just
stayed silent
let's go to The Sisterhood
that's what they call it it's like women
feel the need to protect well I have so
many times when girls in my comments
section will be like why aren't you on
our team it's just like I'm like I'm
just saying what's true it's not even
just a comment section we've had it on
the podcast had a girl attacked me
yeah
[Music]
I've seen that one I've seen that one
they took it down off of YouTube no like
women when women like this is a thing
women know when their girlfriends or
family members are doing bad they're
less likely to acknowledge it which is
why when you talk about The Sisterhood
when a woman breaks away from the herd
she gets called a pick me she gets she
gets called all of these derogatory
names to try and bring her back into The
Sisterhood and shame her for actually
leaving The Sisterhood so yeah The
Sisterhood is uh is very real you know
it is very real I also tend to find that
when I when when I get with a girl and
go on a relationship I tend to attract
more women
I went to a pickup artist conference
where like they would um teach guys how
to get laid basically it's kind of crazy
they pay thousands of dollars to like
fly to one location if one guy literally
teach these men how to get laid you're
right they they sometimes they would
wear a wedding ring because more girls
would like talk to him
and like more like women pre-selection
yeah another fun fact is that women um
the reason I keep saying like women like
red flags it's not just you it's
everyone
um it's because felons have 30 more kids
than non-felons so shout out to us
shout out yeah so is that because you
think that those men display hyper
aggression and women
um they equate hyper aggression to
masculine manliness it's the perception
that's just like I said the perception
there's a perceived notion on these type
of men that women are attracted to the
things that they're scared of in social
way I've seen a girls come up to me when
I've just had a screw face and said
why why you look so angry
kept engaging in conversation trying to
you know figure out where this is going
come to find out that in the end of it
she's asking for my number so I'm
looking at her like you first came
across scared
and now you're attracted so there is a
notion there that there's a lot of truth
to it they're scared to what they're
attracted to because the same thing that
can damage them is a saving that can
save them it's the Superman yeah women
that will initiate fights between men
because it turns them on yeah you know
yeah they like that danger element yeah
we hate that boxers get no play at all
yeah right just do horrible yeah right
but they but they pretend that that they
don't like it me yeah they all say oh my
God they're so barbaric but you know
they watched him and you go at it and
you know their vagina they also need to
understand that women aware what can
kill them
and it's men so they need men that can
kill other men for them they love that
if you know that I can kill people
believe me so much I'm in
um and if you know that I've killed
people
I mean Ted Bundy got hurt
in prison and that's what I mean like
it's not it's not like personal to you
it's just like when you study the female
nature and you look and you look at what
girls pick like yeah we like red flags
just is what it is we can you can like
go to therapy and like pretend we don't
but like we're still attracted to it I
don't think oh I don't think in
categorize all women into that I mean
you're right it's not every single woman
ever but like I think you can say
generalities about a gender without with
like in a conversation we can know
obviously it doesn't mean every single
woman yeah well I think generally but
like I said I think it's an immaturity
thing and it's just I think when a woman
grows up to a grown enough age she's not
like that most women that get married
are in their 30s at that point they're
not marrying red green flags they're mad
they're not marrying red flags they're
marrying green flowers so so yeah you're
right like but to me it's not because
they don't want those guys it's because
they they need the other guys so it's
not because they don't want the Bad Boys
it's because they need the good guy eyes
if they want a family and to have kids
and so a lot of times it's like a mating
strategy they'll get a kid off of the
bad boy and then marry the other guy and
he has to take care of it or they'll get
they'll sleep with all the bad boys and
then find a guy to bail him out with all
their trauma at like 32 31. it's it's it
makes total sense look Lois Lane
was attracted to Spiderman
but there's not Superman Superman but
did not like Clark him so
there is an aura of a masculine man that
attracts women whether it's the
physicality whether it's the aggression
but what what sometimes happens or what
they feel to realize a lot of the time
for the twos to combine it takes time
for a man at early stages of the man's
life he could be one or he could be the
other sometimes it happens quicker for
men sometimes it doesn't but they want
best of both
you have to compromise for some men
sometimes if if that's what you're
attracted to or be smart enough to know
that these red flags are not conducive
for a long-term relationship but that's
why women a lot of women
um especially modern day women get with
men who are bad boys and then try to
turn them yeah yeah and it don't work
they say oh I can try and turn they
don't cheat they don't change
the drug dealer isn't going to get a
stable job I mean if they get back to
serve 10 years maybe after that well
it's too late what are you gonna do
after 10 years in pen when you get a
personal trainer
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I just oh I'll switch I
just got lucky I avoided prison but you
know not everyone gets lucky like I do I
got lucky a lot of ways life is luck
Your Existence is lucky June 2022 1922
we got we're just coming back from war
we are lucky in our only unique
existence do you know where I'm from
I'm from Azerbaijan people calling me
spell that on YouTube go on just like a
mission away 86 I was born over there
you know I mean it's like unique
experience of my life like look where I
am and I've been to many I've been to as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible